you also write in your notes for your
book writing for the green light that
you want to do your best to present a
pitch without looking desperate yes and
you say that looking desperate may get
you a raw deal or at me but it may not
be as favorable I'm curious what are
signs of desperation and why why would
being overconfident get you a better
deal when it's still the script is still
the same but maybe the screenwriters a
little unsure of themselves
when I refer to pitch meetings and I
kind of explained pitch meetings that
the best way to handle a pitch meeting
would be treating it like a first date
the same rules apply in any facet of
business and they apply when you're
pitching your screenplay or just
presenting it in some way if you're on a
first date and you look desperate you
just you give off this really bad
negative vibe you're not confident in
yourself you don't believe in the work
or maybe you're you're when you're
desperate about something you're trying
to push the work as it is and you're not
listening to how to go to party maybe is
kind of saying we prefer it a little bit
more over here we're open to the idea
but we prefer a little bit more like
this and if an individual shying away
from that and desperately holding on to
what they feel it should be initially
they just don't present a very good
image of themselves as being
collaborative desperation can also come
across of an individual's coming to me
let's say and it's a film market or a
film festival I'm not the person they
need to be pitching to and I might
explain that and I might give them a
business card at the right person to go
talk to but they continue pitching their
script to me and I'm not the guy who can
help them and it just kind of has this
vibe of okay look I'm not saying it's a
negative against the screenplay but you
don't necessarily seem to understand the
dynamic of how business works and who to
talk to in that business and and all
that it's it's just it's a it's a slight
little thing where over time too many of
those start to kind of push you know
your opportunities away from you whereas
if you do the opposite
you force yourself to fake confidence
and there's a lot of ways you can do
that you are only you know you you truly
try to listen to what people are telling
you and approach the business in a way
where you're presenting your script and
your ideas in a confident happy fun way
and you're equipped to say you know if
that idea doesn't work for you don't
worry about it or or you're being a
little bit more easygoing with your work
that presents more of like okay this
person understands that Hollywood's an
evolving thing the script is never
really written until the final cut of
the movie is finished you know all those
sorts of nuances so again let's say I'm
in front of the person that is the
decision-maker what are some signs that
are going to give me the appearance of
confidence even if I'm not because
sometimes I think overconfidence to me
is a turn-off I'd actually rather see
more of a real person but I know a lot
of people don't subscribe to that same
belief but what are some things I know
you said being too quick to be defensive
it sounds like that that shows that
you're wounded by the notes and that
maybe it's it's too much for you to
handle but just you're saying again
keeping it light it sounds like we bring
up a really good point you're correct
you can fake in confidence doesn't
necessarily mean being narcissistic and
I I don't mean to come off that way and
have that know leave it but it's it's a
good point you're making you're correct
to fake confidence it's more about just
realizing you're presenting work you're
presenting a blueprint of what could be
a movie but that blueprint is open to
everyone else's ideas as well so you're
correct and saying don't take any
changes or adjustments the heart don't
be too defensive about your work but
also you've got to watch the offensive
part too and not be too in love with
your work not be too self-absorbed with
it and recognize that you're not the
only writer in Hollywood and that you
see it more as a collaboration of
personalities working together to get a
script in motion versus just you as a is
a sole contributor to the script so it's
just that it's just a shift of how to
view the overall relationship
yes looking desperate is you know going
to a film mark at a film festival and
just pitching your ideas to anybody and
everybody who will give you 30 seconds
of their ear looking desperate is being
in an elevator and then realizing you're
next to somebody who's kind of related
to somebody else who has a connection to
a decision maker and then pitching them
your idea awkwardly in an elevator you
know though that's looking desperate
it's it's chasing trends it's it's
inventing scenarios that just aren't
real business opportunities for your
work
you